last week we did a story on this study
about how in 26 the
basically because have an aging
population it's going to stay alive
people riding with kids that are all
economic system can be click Apply
governable
a class war between all people in young
people read Albert Brooks 2030 if you
have been
now futurologists are saying
the there well they're basically making
bold predictions about what's gonna
happen in 2040
to the workforce this is from expat jobs
dot com
nothing like for here are some other
things that they predict will be
happening
by 2040 this is not that long now we may
be requesting Bionic implants for our
and that will make us able to perform
tasks as fast as any machine
plastic surgeons will be able to operate
additional brain processing power
I could use that at the current 37-point
for hour work week will increase
third 250 and a half hours and we will
have left
sex in a lifetime as a result a reduced
human interaction I think somebody's
being there already
happening up a little so let's look at
what the worker will look like in 2014
workers will have red eyes from working
all hours
also maybe from being the Terminator
weaker eyes from close-up wearable
devices much like Google after we talk a
lot about
a smaller penis as a result in fewer
sexual partners over a lifetime
as human interaction reduces I didn't
know that your penis growth in to
YouTube
damage sector having a bigger brain with
software in memory update
in which people will think art in our
era get implanted here where to
eliminate cumbersome Bluetooth headset
and smartphones
and smart fingers with chips that aid
work
okay so I paid the puter 40/20/40 you're
not buying this is such not suck
we're gonna look back at this segment
yeah I have a path dikes I have jobs
that come on
I'm calling shenanigans yeah we're gonna
look back at this segment the same way
we look back a popular Mechanics reviews
from the 40 S
you know I series will fly high above us
like no it's this that won't happen the
idea
that technology can reduce sexual
interaction is crazy if anything we've
seen the exact opposite to be true
right Google glass is not gaining a
foothold anything people are rejecting
the weirdness love it a I think being
conditioned by years and years and years
above dystopian future movies and novels
has made us very suspicious of the
computers that operators tell me every
week every much way too many sci-fi
yeah we're not that we're not going to
be like oh we can have a droid that can
do our jobs
yeah I'd like to hire that droid a
reaction smoke we watch Total Recall
every night before I go to know that you
showed you
yeah because that's just the good life
choice but a
this is just it I mean it's fun to think
about
but it's also crazy okay I'm gonna play
back a little bit on that but I'll let
you go first I'd rip Jack although I do
wanna be
i doing it person is like TV's a fat but
i wanna thought back in the other way
and he's
these guys and believe us we were
totally right you want to be that guy
I wanna be the guy is wrong but I don't
know I think it's all it's it's complete
bullshit but
I do think this expert actually true I
disagree a jack on that I think that
our we have reduced interaction and that
the movie her was like very
true to life or will be break sometime
we'll we will be able to kind of find
connectivity in and server sexual
release outside have
human partners right well already I mean
I don't you know this but there's porn
on the internet
heard yeah I have now and see any but
I've heard that they
yeah I would argue that the last twenty
years have
lead to much more promiscuous why I feel
like
size much more promiscuous now than it
was in nineteen fifties
right and a big part of that is because
we're watching a lot of porn and
were people are getting married much
later in life you know it's
it the number I've twenty-somethings I
know myself included were like
oh I'm not even thinking about getting
married on 30 you like
the would never that would been crazy
talk in nineteen 1950
and you know the rise of tender in
Grindr and its bid
these things are made so people can we
get the right up together looking over
the
right you know record player a good deal
on but yes you can do and I don't think
I don't think anybody's been like
you know porns been so great I'm just
done with sex like I know
I think anything is the opposite right
affect were made
I don't know the I did you could have a
sex robot over having to deal with a
human being
I feel like my cover the segment of a
lot about the sector about their coming
to
no pun intended I they're coming I
I think you're ahead mister I think you
can tell right there about people
the Don Draper's worried about how to
pitch the section with the exact so
okay I'll so I to me it seems like a lot
of this stuff is actually possible
because it only 20 something years in
the future and if you think about what
what we were like twenty years ago we
did not abide by their packet we were
connected to the Internet all-time
we wouldn't even be able to believe all
the stuff we could do now so that's why
I look at this with
and yet maybe our eyes will be turning
red but like the recipe
seemed hyena yeah like we can't nobody
can predict
what what you know there's that famous
quote from the Microsoft guy in like
nineteen
81 is like know where the future will
ever anyone ever need more than four
megabytes of data you know bike I feel
like that's why I kinda buy into this
stuff on my crazy futurist
you're insane I think that no i i get
that I think that
but at the same time a good things that
have happened we've become
accent like exactly now but the things
that happen in the car also kinda in
line with what we
expected to some degree like video calls
I mean
what is actually happening at that
outside of what we could've imagined
right what we thought the video calls
can be on this big machine and it ended
up in our in our hands right but no I
mean that
yeah I these things happen but only
happen in such a extreme ways only by
2040 Rossiya drastically different
I mean there might be a nuclear war that
I pull out before that but def if we
arrive story this paper and yeah I did
we survive I don't leave me that
drastically different
um anything happen kinda gradually as
they're happening is it feels that way
so I don't think it's going to be so way
to wake up suddenly with
I'm robots working our jobs yeah I also
think technology is made us more
connected than maybe I'm buying
what Mark Zuckerberg itself but I do
think technology is made us more
connected than we've ever been
I have met I'm at both the view on the
internet that I
through Twitter and threw it had nothing
to do with them yeah no
yeah well as a rather perks Traci when I
mean I
like this is a human interactions
occurring that would have occurred
talk this is being broadcast earlier
bike its
the were becoming what I don't think
human interaction is
is lessening and I don't think that
anybody
is thinking that poet only I could just
talk to smarter child
are or what it was either like clever
bot or one of those instead of being a
twitter-like interacting with actual
people
a I i think we may have less face to
face contact
at some point but I think there will
always be a need for vases contact and
I think even video calls
where about face to face contact like
it's and even that's not really take I
mean skype is a big part of meetings a
big
but the idea I've like talking to your
friend in the same city on a video call
I still feel like is like not the most
common thing Respir what
you know some TV shows because the
clever it's a easy way to get people the
same room
like I I don't think that's like really
taken off in a huge why I think
in point in 2040 things are gonna look a
lot like they will now only with maybe
like smaller phones
and hope for your water cars frequently
giant retro phone all these Akbar's yeah
go yeah